це третій візит президента Зеленського у
Вашингтон під час повномасштабного
вторнення Росії у Білому домі вже все
готово до Різдва Байден і Зеленський
сидять біля каміна чути як трісю дрова
говорить про різдвяні
подарунки Конгрес має ухвалити додаткове
фінансування для України до того як вони
підуть на канікули і наробити Путіну
найбільший різдвяний Подарунок який вони
могли б йому
зробити ця допомога Україні і є голо
темою переговорів А це понад 61 млрд
доларів для допомоги Україні в рамках
загального пакету допомоги для України
Ізраїлю та безпеки кордонів
США дуже важливо щоб до кінця цього року
ми змогли надіслати агресору дуже
потужний сигнал нашої єдності єдності
України Америки Європи усього вільного
світу усе про що ми сьогодні говорили
допоможе нам у 24му
році
Саме через
2024 рік президентських виборів у США
питання України стало заручником
протистояння між республіканцями і
демократами перші блокують надання нових
коштів Україні і ставлять цю допомогу в
залежність від посилення боротьби з
нелегалами на кордоні США з
Мексикою у динаміці внутрішніх справ США
у внутрішній політиці нині
використовується українське досьє для
передвиборчої гри
республіканці використовують суму грошей
яку адміністрація Джо байдена витрачає
на Україну як передвиборче питання це
використовують проти
президента Крім того ми також бачили що
нещодавнє соціологічне опитування
засвідчило майже 48%в громадян США
вважають що Джо Байден витрачає занадто
багато на
Україну Отже це дійсно політична гра яку
ми бачимо тут у Сполучених Штатах і
можливість впливу президента Зеленського
доволі об
Я не кажу що ситуація безнадійна але я
думаю що буде дуже складно провести
голосування до Різдва враховуючи що
конгрес іде на перерву 15 грудня Однак я
думаю що угода між республіканцями та
демократами буде можливою і пропускаю що
голосування швидше за все відбудеться в
січні Після
канікул але проблема в тому що Україна
не мо може чекати терміново потрібні
ракети артилерійські снаряди та інші
боєприпаси а також військова техніка і
обладнання за оцінками оглядачів навіть
ця одномісячна затримка в наданні
допомоги може мати серйозні наслідки на
полі бою для України та насилатиме
негативні сигнали іншим партнерам щодо
підтримки Києва на зустрічах у
Вашингтоні цей меседж просував і
президент Зеленський проводячи паралелі
з
рейганом якщо когось і можуть надихати
нерозв'язані питання на капітолійському
пагорбі то лише Путіна та його хвору
свиту Вони бачать що мрії стають
реальністю коли бачать затримки та
скандали вони бачать як падає Свобода
коли зменшується підтримка борців за
свободу такі як Путін не мають навіть і
сподіватися що здолають
свободу але ми можемо показати нашим
дітям нашим онукам що таке справжнє
впевненість у собі так як свого часу
вчинив Рональд Рейган у Берліні
закликавши до знесення Берлінської
стіни сьогодні потрібно бути впевненими
в собі так як тоді був впевнений
рейген Джо Байден на зустрічі з
Володимиром Зеленським у Білому домі
оголосив про виділення військової
допомоги Україні на 200 млн доларів і
пообіцяв що ці кошти прийдуть швидко для
цього не потрібна згода конгресу цей
транш один з підсумків візиту
Зеленського у США який вже невдовзі
можна буде відчути інший підсумок
налагодження відносин у конгресі вже на
перспективу за даними джерел ДВ на
голосування по допомозі Україні до
різдвяних канікул це навряд чи вплине
але під час закритої зустрічі у сенаті
зеленському вдалося заручитися
підтримкою багатьох
республіканців головна мета візиту
президента Зеленського у Вашингтон не
лише в тому щоб поговорити з президентом
байденом Ай це навіть важливіше з
партійними лідерами на капітолійському
пагорбі у сенаті та в палаті
представників заради підтримки курсу на
продовження американської підтримки
України особисто для мене все очевидно а
адже понад 70 років принциповий
національний інтерес сполучени штів
полягає у підтримці стабільності та
безпеки в Європі важко зрозуміти як
Європа збереже стабільність і безпеку
якщо Росія переможе Україну і більше
того якщо Росія переможе Україну тоді в
Кремлі можуть почати думати і про інші
країни які колись входили до складу
Радянської
імперії для України нині на карту
поставлено все успіх у цій війні Питання
життя та смерті але як пише New York
Times з посиланням на свої джерела в
український
нереалістичні очікування щодо
можливостей США постачати зброю і
Україні доведеться вести бойові дії зі
скороченим
бюджетоммерикаче американське політичне
життя характеризується компромісами але
для цього адміністрація байдена має
по-перше сформулювати чітко що мета США
- це перемога в Україні а не перемир'я
чи війна на виснаження Україна не може
виграти війну на виснаження проти Росії
у Росії набагато глибша кишеня і
набагато глиб реурси як людські так і
матеріальні тому Україні потрібна
перемога а перемогу можна досягти лише
поставками такої кількості зброї яка
може призвести до поразки російської
арміїче може присти кже росіко ар
спостерігачі у США та Європі сходяться в
одному суперечки та затримки з
фінансовою та військовою допомогою
сприяють просуванню пропаганди Москви
російський впк Швидше адаптувався до
війни аніж промисловість країн ЄС
потужність російських укріплень стала
несподіванкою для американських
стратегів та української армії тим часом
в Європі теж постає питання наскільки
єдиний антиросійський фронт у деяких
країн посилюються позиції не дуже
дружніх до України політичних сил Із
настанням зимових холодів час все більше
грає на користь Кремля обнадійливим
винятком стала хіба що Польща де новим
прем'єром затверджено Дональда туска Ось
що він сказав під час інавгураційної
промови
Ми повинні гучно і твердо одним голосом
говорити про
Україну Це також питання яке має нас
об'єднувати тому що нині ми бачимо як
президент Зеленський знову намагається
переконати світ що на
кону ця війна напад Росії на Україну Це
напад на нас
усіх Я розраховую на співпрацю всіх
політичних сил ми будемо голосно і
рішуче вимагати повної мобілізації
вільного світу західного світу щоб
допомогти Україні у цій війнівта заходу
на поці Україні в й воні альтернативи
цьому способу мислення немає вважає
Дональд Туск в той же час після виборів
у США Україна може стикнутися з ще
більшою проблемою а саме приходом до
влади президента якій не надаватиме
Україні достатньої допомоги для перемоги
у війні проти
Росії
than